hola en efecto principal con la
principal conclusión es que no hay
indicio alguno de que estén aún con vida
los estudiantes por el contrario a todos
los testimonios apuntan a que fueron
ultimados arteramente
también concluyen que se trata de un
crimen de estado pues hubo la
participación de autoridades de los tres
órdenes de gobierno al más alto nivel
incluso entre ellos está el que fuera el
titular de la agencia de investigación
criminal tomás perón que se encuentra
actualmente en tel aviv en israel y con
quien ya se estableció comunicación para
ofrecerle un criterio de oportunidad
para que pueda convertirse en testigo
colaborador y aporte información para
resolver por completo este caso sin
embargo serón se ha negado según refirió
el subsecretario de derechos humanos de
gobernación alejandro encinas dio a
conocer también que ya ha habido 101
acciones de búsqueda se han hallado más
de mil restos socios y hasta el momento
únicamente son tres los estudiantes
plenamente identificados que son los que
ya se tenían conocimiento previamente
dijo que también ya ha habido
colaboración de parte del ejército ha
habido acceso a los cuarteles militares
y que la investigación continúa hay 33
funcionarios que tienen los elementos
suficientes para que se les inicie o se
les continúe una investigación por lo
que continuará esta y también continuará
la búsqueda mário que tanto dista este
documento de las primeras versiones del
caso y la llamada verdad histórica del
presidente enrique peña nieto del ex
presidente enrique peña nieto
fundamentalmente la tesis de aquella
verdad histórica era que los estudiantes
habían sido calcinados en el basurero de
cocula alejandro encinas el
subsecretario de gobernación ha dicho
que nunca estuvieron juntos los
estudiantes en este basurero que fueron
ultimados y desaparecidos en puntos
diferentes
otro elemento es el ya referido de la
participación de autoridades al más alto
nivel incluso del ámbito federal en este
sentido también encina se refirió que
parte de la responsabilidad del ejército
es no haber hecho algo para impedir esa
tragedia toda vez que tuvieron una
alerta recibieron un mensaje de un
elemento en filtrado que les estaba
avisando del ataque del que estaban
siendo víctimas y pudieron haber frenado
y no lo hicieron esto es
fundamentalmente las diferencias y
también el el hecho de reconocer que se
trata de un crimen de estado y que
continuará esta investigación no habrá
carpetas